WE BRING IN PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE OF THE SENATE AND A KEY
COMMISSION SENATOR CHUCK
GRASSLEY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US ON
THIS IMPORTANT AND BUSY
SATURDAY.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
LOTS OF ACTIVITY OVER THERE ON
CAPITOL HILL THIS WEEKEND.
I HAD AN OLD BOSS WHO USED TO
SAY TO ME, DON’T CONFUSE
ACTIVITY FOR OUTPUT.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, SIR,
IS ANY OF THE SPEECHES AND
MEETINGS IMPACT THE OUTCOME,
THE END GOAL FOR MONDAY?
>> NO, IT WILL BE 51-49, 52-48
AND WE KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW, AND
IT WOULD BE A GOOD THING IF
SENATOR SCHUMER WOULD LET US
HOLD RIGHT NOW AND THEN USE THE
REST OF SATURDAY, SUNDAY, AND
MONDAY TO TALK ABOUT THE COVID
LEGISLATION THAT THEY WON’T LET
US BRING UP AS A VOTE EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
I THINK IT’S A GREAT WEEK THAT
WE’RE HAVING, A GREAT WEEKEND
WE’RE HAVING IN THE SENSE OF
GETTING THE THIRD SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED THAT
THE TYPE OF PEOPLE HE’S GOING
TO PUT ON THE SUPREME COURT AND
THIS IS THE THIRD ONE OF THAT
TYPE, WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL A
STRICT CONSTRUCTIONIST AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT DEMOCRATS
NORMALLY PUT ON, JUSTICES THAT
LIKE TO LEGISLATE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO, IT’S A GREAT DAY AND YOU
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
ERNST.
SHE’S HERE THIS WEEKEND WORKING
ON IT AS WELL.
AND IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION, BUT TO GET NINTH
JUSTICE ON, IT’S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO THIS.
GILLIAN: SO, IF THIS GOES
ACCORDING TO YOUR PLAN AND AMY
CONEY BARRETT GETS CONFIRMED--
OR GETS PUSHED THROUGH THE
ENTIRE SENATE MONDAY SHE WILL
DO SO ALONG A PARTY LINE VOTE,
AS YOU MENTIONED, SIR, IT’S THE
FIRST IN HISTORY AND WE KNOW
YOU AND YOUR REPUBLICANS WOULD
RATHER TAKE IT THAN LEAVE IT SO
THIS IS THE BEST YOU COULD DO
RIGHT NOW.
DO YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT,
ABOUT THE PRECEDENT THAT IT
SETS GOING INTO THE FUTURE TO
HAVE NOT A SINGLE MEMBER OF THE
OPPOSITION ENDORSE YOUR
CANDIDATE?
>> WELL, WE HAD THE SAME VOTE
FOR KAVANAUGH, AS YOU KNOW, AND
I THINK WE HAD THE SAME VOTE
FOR GORSUCH.
IT’S A LITTLE DIFFERENT IF YOU
HAVE A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
IF YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT LIKE WE DID WITH THE
TWO DEMOCRATS THAT, LIKE
SOTOMAYOR AND KAGAN, THAT THE
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT PUT ON, A
LOT OF REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR
THEM, BUT I THINK DEMOCRATS
FEEL A LITTLE MORE COMFORTABLE
BEING VERY, VERY PARTISAN ABOUT
IT AS OPPOSED TO REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE SOTOMAYOR AND KAGAN GOT
A LOT OF REPUBLICAN VOTES WHEN
WE HAD A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT AND
EVEN SOME OF THE TIMES WHEN WE
HAD A DEMOCRAT SENATE.
GILLIAN: YEAH, FAIR POINT.
SO FORMER VP JOE BIDEN SAYS
THAT IF HE WINS IN NOVEMBER,
HE’S GOING TO APPOINT POSSIBLY
A SPECIAL COMMISSION TO LOOK
INTO ADDING JUSTICES TO THE
BENCH, WHAT WE COLLOQUIALLY
REFER TO AS COURT PACKING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> WE’VE HAD NINE JUSTICES FOR
150 YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES WHEN
WE’VE HAD LESS THAN NINE
JUSTICES AND I THINK THAT IT’S
THEIR WAY--
OR IT WOULD BE BIDEN’S WAY OF
SATISFYING THE SANDERISTAS, THE
PROGRESSIVE WING OF HIS PARTY
WHO ARE DEMANDING THIS TO PUT A
10TH, 11TH, 12TH, 13TH MEMBER
ON THE SUPREME COURT BECAUSE
THEY WANT A MAJORITY THAT I
DESCRIBED AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUDICIAL ACTIVISTS, PEOPLE THAT
WANT -- WHEN THERE’S A VOID IN
A 50-YEAR-OLD LAW, THEY WILL
SATISFY SAY THE SUPREME COURT
OUGHT TO PUT IT IN.
WELL, THAT’S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BARRETT AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT DEMOCRATS PUT ON
THE SUPREME COURT BECAUSE SHE
SAID, MY JOB IS TO INTERPRET
LAW NOT TO MAKE LAW.
SO, IF THERE’S SOMETHING THAT
YOU DON’T LIKE ABOUT THE STAUT
E, DON’T COME TO THE SUPREME
COURT TO GET THE VOID FILLED
IN.
LET CONGRESS DO WHAT CONGRESS
DOES THAT IS TO LEGISLATE AND
THAT’S THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
OF GOVERNMENT.
GILLIAN: AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
ADDING A JUDGE WOULD MOVE US
TOWARDS POTENTIALLY
POLITICIZING THE COURT, IF
THEY’RE FREE TO ADD JUSTICES AS
THEY WANT TO GOING FORWARD, AND
SETS A PRECEDENT THAT NOT A LOT
THEY’RE COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND DEMOCRATS SAY NOTHING IN
THE CONSTITUTION PREVENTS US
FROM DOING IT AND REPUBLICANS
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF RUSHING
THROUGH SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
HAS BROUGHT US TO THIS PLACE
WHERE THE RULES ARE NOW, WE
WILL DO WHATEVER WE CAN.
NO HOLDS BARRED.
>> WELL, THAT’S WHERE THIS
ELECTION ALL COMES ABOUT, WITH
SENATOR SCHUMER, LET’S SAY,
PUTTING IN $200 MILLION IN IOWA
TO BEAT JONI ERNST BECAUSE HE
WANTS TO TAKE CONTROL OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AND HE
SAYS EVERYTHING IS ON THE
TABLE.
PACKING THE SUPREME COURT ARE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE ON
THE TABLE AND ALSO DOING AWAY
WITH THE 60-VOTE REQUIREMENT IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE SO
THEY CAN DO THINGS IN A
PARTISAN WAY.
TODAY THE SENATE IS THE ONLY
INSTITUTION IN OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM FORCES BIPARTISANSHIP
BECAUSE 53 REPUBLICANS CAN’T
GET ANYTHING DONE, I’M TALKING
LEGISLATION NOT JUDGES.
YOU CAN’T PASS A BILL UNLESS
YOU’VE GOT BIPARTISAN FOR IT.
YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP THE 60-VOTE
REQUIREMENT IN THE SENATE.
GILLIAN: THANK YOU, SENATOR FOR
TAKING TIME OUT FOR AN